Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This is the way. A lot of you spotted Sam
Witwer's name during the Ahsoka episode
1 in Episode 2 credits.
And there have been a ton,
a ton of theories
about who he's actually playing.
What is that secret cameo?
Because of me posting this video.
He hasn't said anything publicly about it.
And usually he does that.
Right after his and or a cameo aired,
he was posting all about it.
your feeble skills
match for the power of the darkside?
since then I've rewatched Ahsoka Episode
1 and Episode 2.
I think we figured out who he is.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I'm doing videos
for all the Ahsoka episodes every week.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
And if you haven't seen my episode
one Episode 2 video
all link those below in the description
at the end of this.
We're still in the middle of that
echo dot.
Star Wars giveaway.
I'll just keep that going until I run out
of all the extra ones that they sent me.
And then we'll switch the giveaway
to something else every week.
All you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber
and just post all your Sam Witwer theories
in the comments.
Careful for spoilers for Episode 1 in
Episode 2 if you haven't seen them yet.
But during the credits
for the first two episodes, you see Sam
Witwer in a couple other familiar people
that show up as additional voices.
zoom in enhancing
or Matthew would is a good example.
He's one of the Lucasfilm sound editors
that's been working at Skywalker
Sound for years.
He's on background voices in smaller
characters on pretty much
all the Star Wars series in the movies.
Since the prequels
like he was the voice of General Grievous
during Revenge of the Sith,
he did the Battle Droids voices
during the Clone Wars.
So like, he's all over the Place is lesser
characters in voices that don't
necessarily have a ton of speaking lines
the same is true for everyone here
under additional voices in Hollywood
productions, movies, TV shows like this.
The credit usually means
the voice that they're doing.
Is it for a character
that has an actual name,
but they have some kind of background,
lesser speaking part that they need
for scenes?
no. Someone plays a character
that has a speaking part
and they appear visibly on screen
in a slightly bigger way.
Or their character has a name.
Usually they had put in the main
part of the credits here, like this.
That's usually when the part is way,
way bigger.
Now, Sam Witwer is mostly known as
the voice of Darth Maul during Clone Wars.
He also came back as the voice of Darth
Maul during Rebels.
He also came back during Solo, a Star Wars
story for live action maul.
But they did the hybrid where they had Rey
part come back as a physical performance
and he just is the voice over.
Kind of like a James Earl Jones
Darth Vader situation.
Play with the attitude you have.
I like the attitude of it all. Okay.
All right. In my mind's eye,
can you be
go now that I
Longtime Star Wars
fans also know him
as Galen Merrick Starkiller from the Force
Unleashed Video Game, who is a now
non-canonical apprentice of Darth Vader.
After Anthony and Skywalker became Darth
Vader, He's legends can and currently
since Disney has bought Star Wars like
Starkiller has not become Canon again.
at least right now, Ahsoka is meant to be
the only canonical apprentice
and again Skywalker ever had.
And so far Darth Vader
has had no canonical apprentices
since he turned to the dark side.
That could always wind up changing.
some point someone said, and let's pretend
like it was George Wright. So here goes.
Yeah. All right.
You know, what you should do for video
games is you should a guy who looks like
he doesn't just sound like the part,
but he looks like the part.
And you can we can use our ILM technology
to put him in the game.
Probably not.
Just because
they want to hone in on this relationship
between Ahsoka and against Skywalker
in her relationship.
And again, when he became Darth Vader,
like they're focusing on these two
particular people.
that's what a lot of the Antique
and Skywalker cameo scenes are probably
going to be specific to on the Ahsoka
series, like flashbacks to her remembering
an account before he became Darth Vader,
like during the Clone Wars
when she was younger,
and then after he became Darth Vader
in the trauma that she experienced
with all that in order 66
but seeing Witwer shows up in cameo scenes
all over the place,
like all over the Star Wars
TV shows, the live action stuff,
even the live action Star Wars
movies, the Star Wars video games
they've been doing the last several years.
most of you started noticing this
during the Mandalorian episodes
Book of Boba Fett and or Episodes.
He just guest starred in a ton of cameo
roles pretty much all over the place.
In a lot of times when he has
these cameo scenes doing additional voices
or background characters, he doesn't
always use his normal speaking voice.
so it doesn't always sound like actual
Sam Witwer is doing
the voice, really good example of this
was during the book of Boba Fett.
He played that Rhodey and Prisoner that
Boba Fett talked to that in episode four.
He was the chef droid. Oh, God.
Oh, Neither
of those voices sounded like Sam Witwer,
like nobody spotted him
until after the episodes came out
and he was posting about it
on social media like,
Hey, did anybody spot me in the episodes?
Mark Hamill does stuff like this too.
Like he played
the 99 Droid during The Mandalorian.
Sounded
absolutely nothing like Mark Hamill.
Like nobody would have known it was him
unless he posted about it, said with words
and or a cameo during and or price
and the closest to his normal voice.
Also his cameo during Rogue One,
during Andor.
He was the short trooper
who arrests him at the resort.
when his name popped up in the credits
after Ahsoka Episode 1 in Episode 2,
everyone was wondering
who he was playing on the show.
And there have been a ton,
a ton of theories.
People think that he's
going to be the voice of Merak
and do the physical appearance
when the Inquisitor helmet comes off.
so many Merak theories right now,
like Merak secretly being a big character,
the actor currently doing the physical
on screen performance,
like doing all the actual lightsaber
fighting is a stunt actor.
They're doing kind of a Mandalorian thing
where they have a stunt actor play
that physical performance in the play,
have somebody else come and do the voice.
When the helmet comes off.
during the Mandalorian episodes, Pedro
Pascal just does The voice,
and they have other actors
underneath the armor in most episodes,
unless he needs to take his mask off.
But that was a whole big thing.
The last couple of seasons
is not taking his helmet off.
because of all this saying Witwer stuff.
Now, I started seeing theories
that Merak is secretly going
to be a canonical version of Star Killer
Galen Merrick.
I've seen all the Ezra Bridger
Merak theories too.
Those are all still possible.
But here's the thing
If you rewatch the episodes and listen
really carefully to all the voices
you hear in the episode,
like all the background, the lesser
voices, two people that are off screen,
they just have voicing parts.
You don't actually see their faces.
h k droids sound a lot like Sam was voice.
If it was processed to sound droid
like in mechanical
the way they do with David Tennant's
voice when he does who Yang
remember he did the Rodion
prisoner's voice and he didn't use
his normal sounding voice for that.
there even some people out there
that think that he's just going to be
the voice of the lost cat in both episodes
and he's just making funny cat noises.
And that's why he got the secret cameo
credit under additional voices.
even start showing up in the credits
for most of the episodes
under Additional Voices?
I think that will confirm that
he's probably the voice of the HK droids
because Thrones HK Droids might continue
to pop up in most of the episodes.
And he also might be voicing
other background characters, not just the
HK droids, when it comes to the Rock's
secret identity based on everything
Jon Favreau,
Dave Filoni have said and done
when it comes to fan theories,
huge deep cuts from the lore like this.
Usually the truth of these reveals
winds up being way, way simpler
than everyone thinks.
for example, who saved Grogu
at the Jedi Temple during Order 66?
a couple of years ago
when they started teasing this out.
I had an awesome theory about Mannequin
Skywalker and Emperor Palpatine
that totally made sense
in explaining some of the twists later
during the original trilogy.
But in reality they just said that it was
Keller and Beck who saved him.
Ahmed Best, mostly known
as Jar Jar Binks from the prequels,
Dave Filoni and the Lucasfilm people
thus far have only said officially that
Mark was a former inquisitor
and after the fall of the Empire,
after the collapse of the Inquisitors,
he just started
working as a mercenary, eventually
being hired by Morgan Elsbeth lady.
Elsbeth definitely pays people well,
Morag serves under Balan skull.
But Balan isn't his master,
and he's not his apprentice.
They're just part of the same mercenary
team.
And Balan school just happens to be a way
more experienced, way more powerful.
Master
I just did in Episode 3 trailer video
where I explained the Maroc
Ezra time travel theory.
But right now I mostly think
Morocco will just wind up being
a regular inquisitor like nobody's
special, like the way people expect.
never even been some bearers
off theories out there.
I don't think that it's going to wind up
being her either.
I think it's probably a dude like a male
in Morocco is just a normal inquisitor.
part of the reasons why
I think they're having a former inquisitor
be part of this series
and fight is so because so much like
they'll have a rematch during episode
3 or episode 4,
I think is just to hearken back
to the way that she got
her newer light saber sabers,
like she got her twin lightsabers
after defeating an inquisitor
in purifying the light saber crystals.
just to be clear, though,
the inquisitor she defeated to get
her new lightsabers was not Burak.
That was a completely different
inquisitor.
there's some great theories out there,
but I don't think any of them right now
about maroc are true necessarily.
I definitely don't think
that is the canon version of Starkiller
even though that would be super cool.
And yes, it is still totally possible
that Sam Witwer is playing Merak on screen
when the mask comes off.
really waiting for Sam Witwer
to actually play
like a real big live action
onscreen character,
not just these one off cameo scenes
that are always under helmets.
a little while ago,
he did say that he was hoping
for a live action
star killer series at some point.
That's always possible.
I mean, never say never.
Dave Filoni is famous for re
canonizing legends stuff.
Thrawn is probably the most famous
example of that.
During rebels
now we're getting a bunch of Thrawn movies
that they'll probably do
a trilogy of Thrawn movies
that this first one goes, Well,
going to pay off
that heir to the Empire trilogy
that everybody back in
the nineties is going to go crazy about.
I would have never thought
reading those original Thrawn
trilogy books in the nineties that we
would get to see movie versions of those
let me know in the comments though.
Who do you think Merauke is really going
to wind up being and what do you think?
Sam Witwer is cameo
Things have been for him to be included
in this credits like it would have to be
some background character
there are bunch of other Ahsoka videos
that I'm working on,
so I'll post those as soon as possible.
My full Episode 3 video will post
after airs next week.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
and let me know
if you have any special questions
about the characters or what's going on
or requests for bonus videos, click here
for my Episode 3 video and click here
for all my Ahsoka episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!